[Music]
as joe biden's leadership sucks
hunter's paintings are making bucks
at least five of hunter's paintings have
already been sold for 75 000
each that's according to the new york
post which is owned by our parent
company crisco
apparently the
georges burgess gallery sold the prince
prior to a show opening last week in l.a
where hunter welcomed 200 celebrity
guests and prospective buyers yep he's a
modern warhol emphasis on whole
now
the identities of the buyers remained
anonymous perhaps because they're not
allowed to buy art as a condition of
their parole
but clearly the idea of keeping a veil
of secrecy around all this isn't
happening and as former white house
ethics chief richard painter painter his
name is painter
points out
point this is an ethics problem for the
president
this is an ethics problem for the
see i told you
[Applause]
i told you he was going to say that
continue
cannot have the impression
that the executive branch will be doing
favors for anyone who does business with
the president's family transparency is
the answer not trying to keep things
secret
this guy's got to move back from the
camera
it's your first day on zoo yes
it's like a muppet all right so now a
team of lawyers is reportedly vetting
patrons for uh hunter's upcoming gallery
show in new york city which has been
delayed until spring or as hunter calls
it fresh cocaine season
loftist
his art is almost as bad as your
wardrobe
do you feel bad that somehow he is
making money off his terrible talent and
you can't
[Laughter]
yes
thank you i do you know what and i'll
probably be investigated by the fbi
before he is too
yeah it's really crazy every time i see
something about like hunter biden
anonymously you know people are buying
his paintings because he's such a
wonderful talent i'm just like is the
fbi ever going to do anything they've
had this guy's laptop since 2018. but
seriously it's like it's just a horrible
embarrassment
to the country to the fbi good lord
they're out investigating pta parents
dude i'm trying to get a gun permit
which i talk about all the time that guy
broke every gun law with it remember he
threw the gun away in a garbage can
yeah leaves rental cars in the middle of
a desert with cocaine and pipes and
badges and like get out of here like i
say when i hear more about him carly i
like him
but he's gonna be the only one yeah no
but he's like the only person benefiting
under the biden economy yeah
yeah seven what was it seventy five
thousand a painting yes
yes i think that hunter biden is
probably the best example of how uh
really the media is still aggressively
trying to
protect uh president biden because um
it's not just that he was a crack addict
or failed to
pay child support or
tried to profit off his dad's political
career but we live in a time that is so
hyper focused on race and he used the
n-word in a series of racist texts and
the media didn't even cover that's a
good point i forgot you know there's so
many things about hunter we forgot that
he's the racist yeah so if you buy that
artwork you're buying the artwork
of a racist or something that's
comfortable with using that kind of
language by the way that reminds me kat
do you remember when the police came
because he had dumped his gun
into a or his wife had dumped the gun
into a trash can and when they were
interviewing him he said see those
mexicans remember he said see those
mexicans over there probably illegal
yeah probably do you remember that i i
mean do you remember that story
yeah that's an issue right did i dream
this no
no it's real it's real
that's an interesting response to
protect yourself from cancer culture
you're really right okay i'm a horrible
racist what do i do become a crackhead
and don't pay child support
because nobody will care about that i
mean look it's obvious that these
paintings are you know a way to pedal
influence either that or he's like the
greatest artist of all time freda's
first try which that's not true one of
those paintings looked like something
came out of my nose after my surgery
truthfully
but the sad thing is that we even live
in a political system where having the
favor of the executive son is even worth
anything because that's not how it was
supposed to be like when this country
was set up you could be the president's
best buddy in the world and it wouldn't
matter because they didn't have all this
power and control over all of our daily
lives those decisions are supposed to be
made by the individual
good points thank you
i actually posed this idea to uh
45 uh a month ago he trump's kids should
start selling their own art
and but give it i mean think about this
but give it all to charity which makes
so what that forces hunter to give away
all of his money they should do that
like tomorrow make do it stitch figures
whatever
clown clown art spin art that's a
brilliant idea yeah no it is but they we
didn't have it in the interview because
it was the interview was too long but
anyway we'll get into the behind the
scenes stuff but that's
that's i think that's that's
should be the solution to this what do
you think i like that idea i also think
that if hunter minded wanted to be
transparent that he's he should just
release the list of who's buying it
because what concerns me from a national
security perspective is what is foreign
intel buying it or are you know are
russian oligarchs i mean you go through
the list of things that we don't know
but what i really miss hearing this
whole segment being the last one to talk
i miss george w bush's art remember his
like his first one the painting it was
like the selfie of him in the bathtub
and it was really weird
why did you paint that i missed that it
was so basic almost by the numbers
though i don't think it was by the
numbers that it was surreal it was just
a very doesn't his art go to help uh
veterans yes
i don't think he makes a profit off of
it yeah yeah that's why but hunter's
like no it's just coming to me
hookers don't pay for themselves
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else